ah
[Música]
internet transformó nuestra sociedad de
eso creo que no hay nadie que tenga
dudas
hoy podemos hacer cosas con internet que
hace 30 o 40 años
creíamos imposibles
y día a día podemos hacer nuevas cosas
que nos sorprenden y nos dejan
maravillados
pero en la internet que estamos viviendo
hoy o que la mayoría de nosotros vivimos
es la que nosotros llamamos la internet
del conocimiento
y que es la internet del conocimiento
que fue lo que hizo también la internet
del conocimiento y que hizo que
cambiáramos tanto como sociedad lo que
hizo la interna del conocimiento fue
hacer muy fácil muy simple muy barato
muy rápido muy eficiente el intercambio
de datos de información y de
conocimiento
yo recuerdo cuando yo era chico iba a la
escuela y tenía que hacer un trabajo
mis fuentes de información o de
conocimiento eran físicas yo primero
tenía que generalmente iba a una revista
que se llamaba echaron a
y entonces iba buscaba información
recortaba pegaba etcétera cuando lázzaro
no me quedaba chica
agarraba la enciclopedia de casa que
teníamos una que la había heredado de mi
hermano tenía unos cuantos años
seguramente
cuando el enciclopedia me quedaba chica
iba a la biblioteca de mi colegio o de
mi barrio donde tenía un abanico más
grande de conocimiento a mi disposición
y cuando encontraba en un libro
específico que me pudiese servir por un
tiempo largo para muchas materias
etcétera iba a la librería y si tenía
suerte de que hubiese stock lo compraba
por pero era muy selectivo porque son
acá eran caros los libros en general me
gustaba mucho tener libros pero eran
caros
internet cambio todo esto internet hizo
posible que cualquier persona en
cualquier parte del mundo con un celular
o con cualquier dispositivo con acceso a
internet tenga acceso a todo el
conocimiento del mundo tenga acceso a
trabajos hechos por las mejores
universidades del mundo tenga acceso al
ciclo pedidas mucho más actualizadas o
completas que la que yo tenía y tenga
acceso por ejemplo si yo quiero tener un
libro tengo siempre stock voy lo compró
a un precio bastante razonable y lo está
leyendo en pocos segundos
hoy por hoy mis hijas e incluso yo
cuando tenemos que hacer
un trabajo una investigación seguramente
nuestra primera fuente de consulta sea
internet
pero hay algo que hasta hace unos años
era imposible hacer en internet y que
seguramente la mayor parte de ustedes
todavía nunca lo han hecho y es
transmitir valor
ustedes seguramente nunca han podido
transmitir valor a través de internet
y ustedes me dirán pero yo hace años
entró a la web de mi banco y hago
transferencias o entro un y commerce
como amazon mercadolibre y hago pagos
con mi tarjeta de crédito pero ustedes
ahí no están atrás transmitiendo o
transfiriendo valor ustedes ni siquiera
tuvieron el valor que se transfirió
ustedes le pidieron a un intermediario
ya sea un sello de una tarjeta de
crédito o un banco que hiciera la
transferencia de valor por ustedes
ustedes nunca pudieron tras transferir
valor y hasta hace unos años era
imposible hacerlo por internet
hasta finales del 2008 y principios del
2009 que surge una nueva tecnología
llamada bitcoin y que es bitcoin bitcoin
es la primer cripto moneda que existe o
la primer grito moneda exitosa en
concreto a manera me refiero es una
moneda 100% digital es una moneda
descentralizada que lo que intenta es
eliminar la necesidad de esos
intermediarios y por primera vez estamos
pudiendo transferir valor por internet
para crear bitcoin se tuvo que crear una
nueva tecnología que inicialmente no
tenía nombre
y hoy conocemos como block chain
y nosotros decimos que cuando se creó
bitcoin se crearon dos productos o dos
tecnologías bitcoin y blogs en y que
blogging es mucho más abarcativa o tiene
muchas más aplicaciones incluso que
bitcoin vamos a intentar describir un
poco después
y que desbloquee tienes una base de
datos
orientada a transacciones todo dentro de
la base de datos de blogs es una
transacción es completamente distribuida
qué quiere decir que existen muchas
copias de esa misma base de datos
en el caso de bitcoin miles de copias
distribuidas en el mundo es
descentralizada que quiere decir que no
hay un solo ente centra el banco o
entidad o empresa que la controle que
controle qué es lo que ocurre dentro que
está permitido dentro de esa base de
datos sino que todos aquellos que
participan o que integran la plataforma
deciden en construyen en consenso en
conjunto qué decisiones deben tomarse
y esto permitió varias cosas primero
permite la posibilidad de crear un nuevo
sistema financiero un sistema financiero
que es abierto que para acceder a él
solo necesito internet y un celular un
sistema financiero donde no está
controlado por un ente central o por un
gobierno y mucho mejor donde la
confianza no está depositada en un
gobierno o en un banco central yo no
tengo que confiar en que mi banco
central no se va a dar vuelta y va a
imprimir 10 billones más de mi moneda y
la va a ser valer menos eso está la
confianza se traslada a confiar en
matemática criptografía y código de
computadora
y hay otro tema que es inmutabilidad de
nosotros dijimos que blogs tienes una
base de datos inmutabilidad siempre nos
referimos a algo que no puede
modificarse
algo que una vez que toma una forma no
puede modificarse las blue screen en
general
tienen que ser inmutables pues eso
quiere decir que una vez que un dato
ingresó en la blog change no puede ser
modificado ni eliminado la blocks y
termina siendo como un libro contable de
contabilidad es que existe hace cientos
o miles de años y si ustedes lo conocen
es un registro donde solo se pueden
agregar nuevas cosas y si hay un error
hay que crear una nueva entrada que
corrija el error anterior nunca se puede
modificar ni eliminar
pero para cumplir esto los blogs tienen
que cumplir ciertas características por
el hecho de estar o blogs change no es
inmutable la block sing de bitcoin es
inmutable
entonces en bitcoin tenemos una base de
datos universal distribuida
donde hay miles de copias de la misma en
todo el mundo donde yo mismo puedo tener
una copia ahora mismo cualquiera de
ustedes se baja en el software y
empiezan a colaborar con la red y tienen
una copia y pueden empezar a votar
porque se puede aceptar que no
y es una base de datos inmutable y es
una base de datos en donde se confían
en la criptografía matemática y ahí se
abre un nuevo abanico de aplicaciones o
de casos de uso por ejemplo guardar
prueba de existencia de documentos
dentro de esta base de datos imagínense
por ejemplo una universidad que al
expedir sus certificados de grado lo
guarde laguardia una prueba de los
mismos dentro de una bloc change es
inmutable nunca nadie lo va a poder
modificar es abierto cualquiera puede
acceder desde cualquier parte del mundo
pueden consultar y validar que ese
certificado existe sin siquiera
contactar a la universidad si la
universidad deja de existir ese dato va
a seguir existiendo y mucho mejor es muy
fácil con criptografía validar que quien
agregó ese dato fue la universidad y ya
tenemos que empezar a dejar de confiar
en sellos de goma un poco de tinta y una
secara pela de papel que son bastante
fáciles de falsificar y empezar a
confiar en criptografía y matemática y
código
de computadoras y la tercera cosa que
quisiera comentarles sobre un launcher
es los acuerdos descentralizados
blogging se creó para soportar bitcoin
como dije y para eliminar la necesidad
de ese intermediario para transferir
valor y gente muy inteligente dijo [ __ ]
y por qué no usamos lo mismo para los
contratos que firmamos diariamente
nosotros diariamente firmamos contratos
en papel donde ponemos condiciones y
acciones
y tenemos que confiar en la buena fe de
la otra parte que la va a cumplir cuando
una de las dos partes no cumplen tenemos
que ir a un tercero con suficiente
autoridad para hacer cumplir a la otra
parte un tercero puede ser un juez puede
ser una comisión puede ser una directiva
etcétera entonces dijeron por qué no
usamos las capacidades de blogging de
eliminar intermediarios para poder
eliminar también la necesidad de esos
terceros entonces el programa el
contrato en código en un lenguaje de
programación donde se especifican qué
condición pues que cuando ocurran
determinadas condiciones qué acciones
deben ocurrir y cuando la plataforma
como plataforma de determina que las
condiciones se cumplieron las acciones
se ejecutan y eso es lo que se llaman
los contratos inteligentes y esto abrió
una nueva gama mucho más amplia de
posibles aplicaciones en seguros en
trazabilidad en logística
[Música]
bitcoin y blogging dio inicio a una
nueva internet la que llamamos internet
del valor
en la internet del valor nos da ciertas
características ciertas cosas que yo
quiero compartir con ustedes que me
parecen súper interesantes una ya le
dijimos posibilidad de transferir valor
a través de internet por primera vez en
la historia ahora yo le puedo pagar a
amazon directamente no necesito un
intermediario o le puedo transferir
dinero a otra persona directamente no
necesito un intermediario la siguiente
quisiera ejemplificar la con un un
ejemplo queda un amigo que a mí me gusta
mucho imagínense hay un extraterrestre
que viene y nos empieza a estudiar como
especie el estado un tiempo mirándonos y
se vuelve a su planeta
se junta con sus colegas extraterrestres
y se buena estuve estudiando esta
civilización esta especie que presenta
ciertos destellos de inteligencia ellos
han logrado decodificar su propio adn
saben cómo estaban compuestos más o
menos han logrado ir a su satélite
natural que llama luna por alguna razón
clavaron a la bandera y se volvieron
y ahora están pensando colonizar un
planeta cercano que se llama amarte
ahora lo interesante de esta
civilización que parece presenta estos
destellos de inteligencia es que cuando
se les pide almacenar valor de forma
segura por mucho tiempo parecen ardillas
preparándose para el invierno hacen un
pozo sacan unos metales amarillos que se
llama oro lo funden en unos bloques
vuelven a hacer un pozo y lo entierran y
esa es la forma que hemos encontrado de
guardar valor almacenar o valor por
largos periodos de tiempo de forma
segura
bitcoin por primera vez permite por
primera vez en miles de años permite
almacenar nosotros mismos valor
digitalmente de forma segura
y el internet de valor da un par de
cositas más yo quiero contarles una
historia personal
yo soy cofundador de la empresa de
software y hace unos 10 años cuando
arrancamos la empresa con mi socio
empezamos a trabajar en unos abrimos la
empresa empezamos a trabajar en unos
proyectos chicos de conocidos etcétera
al cabo de unos meses
conseguimos la posibilidad de un
contrato con un cliente en el exterior
muy grande grande para nosotros nos iba
a cambiar como empresa
llegó el momento de firmar el contrato y
en el contrato nos dimos cuenta que nos
pedía un número de cuenta bancaria a
nombre de la empresa en ese momento
nosotros no teníamos habíamos trabajado
siempre en proyectos chicos cobramos con
cheque y efectivos vimos no hay problema
vamos al banco y creamos una cuenta
para nuestra sorpresa fuimos al banco y
nos empezaron en aquel entonces a pedir
un montón de requerimientos que no
podíamos cumplir
por ejemplo nos decían necesitan
traernos un contrato con un cliente un
contrato activo y nosotros eran hasta
ese momento contratos de palabra y
queríamos la cuenta para firmar el
primer contrato y la cuenta y el
contrato nos pedía la cuenta entonces
estábamos con un huevo y gallina
se nos estaban venciendo los plazos se
nos estaba por quedar el contrato por
suerte un amigo de un familiar trabajaba
en un banco y nos habilitó y nos confió
en nosotros y nos creó una cuenta
pudimos hacer el contrato de todos
comimos perdices pero a mí me quedaron
dos sentimientos el primero fue de
impotencia porque nosotros realmente
necesitábamos esa cuenta porque nos iba
a cambiar como empresa y estábamos
dispuestos a hacer todo lo que estuviese
a nuestro alcance darles toda la
información que nos pidieran darles
absolutamente todo nada era suficiente
nos excluyeron igual y nada era
suficiente y luego fue de resignación
fue decir bueno está el mundo funciona
sí bancátela por suerte tuviste la
fortuna de encontrar una chicana
pero tal vez con estos nuevos sistemas
financieros
exista la posibilidad de evitar esas
cosas el internet del valor también es
inclusión hay cerca un 50 por ciento de
la población mundial que no tiene acceso
al sistema financiero tradicional no
tiene cuenta bancaria en la américa
latina es un poco peor es más de un 60 y
del porcentaje que si tiene acceso un
gran porcentaje de este no está
integrado financieramente que quiero
decir no tiene acceso a préstamos no
tiene acceso a créditos posibilidades de
inversión etcétera
y con estas nuevas tecnologías llegó el
momento de pensar en esta segunda mitad
porque en mi caso si no me salía el
contrato era un contrato tarde o
temprano la cuenta me la iban a dar y
vamos a pelearla de una forma pero estoy
seguro que muchas esta gente de estas
personas sufren la misma impotencia pero
es una impotencia mucho peor mucho más
cruda una impotencia de no poder tener
capacidad de ahorro una impotencia de no
poder pedir un préstamo para pagar la
educación de tus hijos o una impotencia
de no pedir un préstamo para pagar un
tratamiento de una enfermedad internet
los cambios no son mejores nos mejora
como sociedad pero ya tenemos las
herramientas para poder integrar
financieramente a la otra mitad a la
segunda mitad y poder nuevamente
mejorarnos como especie muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
ah